Він - серед гущі людей у центрі Берліна,
але відчуває себе невидимим.
Три роки тому Міхал приїхав з Польщі
з невеликим рюкзаком до німецької столиці.
Відтоді він спить на вулиці.
Спершу я спав тут під мостом на Александерплатц.
Тоді нас була ціла група - 10 або 15 людей, які спали тут.
Всі з Польщі. Згодом до нас приєдналися інші, кілька російськомовних.
Зрозуміло, свої до своїх.
Кожен залишається у своїй групі.
Дедалі більше мігрантів зі Східної Європи живуть, як Міхал, на вулицях Берліна.
За різними оцінками, від трьох до десяти тисяч.
Офіційних цифр немає.
Міхал вже давно втратив сподівання знайти житло в німецькій столиці
й облаштував своє життя на вулиці.
Він знає переважну більшість тутешніх безпритульних.
акож цю молоду полячку.
Бомжі захищають один одного від нападів та насилля.
Особливо вночі.
Стільки різних ситуації траплялося, на які не маєш впливу.
Зростання кількості безпритульних непокоїть мешканців міста.
Дехто боїться за свою безпеку і чинить тиск на місцеву владу.
Чиновники самі визнають: їхні ресурси обмежені,
ситуація поволі виходить з-під контролю.
Ми не знаємо, що може трапитися, якщо розігнати цих людей.
Якщо сказати їм: ви не можете більше тут спати,
чи не почнуть вони кидати у вас пляшками або обливати сечею.
Усе це вже траплялося, як розповідають наші працівники.
І щонайпізніше тоді стає зрозуміло:
ми не можемо вирішити соціальні проблеми поляків, угорців, румунів
у наших зелених зонах.
Берлін - як магніт для східних європейців, розповідає Міхал.
Тут легко жити без грошей, оскільки існує багато різних соціальних установ.
Сам він двічі на тиждень приходить у центр для молодих безпритульних:
аби випрати одяг, виспатися, поїсти.
Працівники центру вважають, що політики довший час заплющували очі на проблему безпритульності.
Лише коли кількість новоприбулих зі Східної Європи разюче зросла,
ця тема стала предметом обговорення серед громадськості.
Потрібно визнати, що європейці не лише з добрих міркувань користуються свободою пересування.
Але гадаю, що висилка таких людей - не вихід.
Багато безпритульних  просто не хочуть назад -
з абсолютно різних причин.
Можливість повернення таких людей назад обговорюється нині між Німеччиною та Польщею.
Незабаром на вулицях Берліна польські соціальні працівники намагатимуться
переконати безпритульних співвітчизників повернутися на батьківщину.
Ні, я в жодному разі не хочу назад до Польщі.
Просто занадто багато всього сталося.
Мої спогади…  Якщо я повернуся, то щось скою, то навіщо?
У мене там донька і це дуже важко для мене.
Коли я там, то чиню лише щось лихе.
І цього Міхал боїться більше, ніж холодної зими на вулиці.
Одного дня він хоче пояснити своїй доньці, що пішло шкереберть у його життя.
Але доти він воліє залишатися невидимим на вулицях Берліна.